A seven year old arrives home with her first
report card from school, which is full of
terrible grades.
Her dad leans over her shoulder to take a
peek at the academic horror show.
The girl turns around and asks: So what do
you think dad?
Nature or nurture?
Centuries ago, John Locke and others, began
arguing that our personality is mainly shaped
by the environment we were raised in.
Others, such as Charles Darwin, believed that
we are largely programmed genetically.
Modern behavioral geneticists think that it’s
more complex - because the two interact.
And relatively recently, a little crayfish
from Germany, showed just how little we actually
know — but more about her later.
First, let's go back to the girl, her dad
and what we do know.
Neither the dad, nor the smartest scientists,
can answer what leads to certain school outcomes
of our 7-year old girl.
We do know, however, a bit about the influences
of genes and the environment when it comes
to groups of specific populations.
Take, for example, a group of 100 white American
men in their early twenties and you will probably
find, on average, an IQ of 100, a height of
178 cm or around 5.8 feet, and that ten have
spelling problems.
We can now ask which of these 3 traits is
determined by genes — anything that happened
before conception, often referred to as nature;
and which by the environment— anything that
happened after their mothers got pregnant,
often referred to as nurture.
To understand the two forces,
we need to acknowledge
that environmental influences are often random
— siblings experience home very differently.
And we need to recognize that genes are complex
— there is no single gene doing a single
thing.
We therefore know little about which trait
in an individual is the result of their genetic
makeup and which is due to the environment.
We only know about the impact of nature and
nurture on trait differences of a particular
group.
And to learn about that, we need to understand
heritability.
Heritability is a factor that ranges between
one and zero.
One stands for genetic influences.
Zero for environmental factors.
Heritability defines the genetic impact on
trait differences in a particular population.
It can not measure the degree to which a trait
of a particular individual is genetic.
Dyslexia, for example, has a heritability
closer to 1.
That means that genes explain more of the
difference in spelling mistakes of our group
than school, family or random factors.
It does not mean that one particular person
with spelling problems got them genetically.
Some just didn’t get much support when they
were young.
How complex the interaction between genes
and environment really is becomes clear when
we look at something as seemingly straightforward
as IQ and height.
First, let’s examine height.
A group of 100 white American male students
are on average 178 centimeters tall — that’s
roughly five feet, 10 inches.
Their heritability for height is around 0.8.
If some men in this group are 183 cm — or
six feet tall, then heritability allows us
to assume that 80% of that difference is,
on average, caused by genetic variants and
20% of the difference is due to lifestyle.
If the same group of people were raised in
a region that experienced systemic droughts
and they never had enough to eat, their potential
for an average height of 178 centimeters is
far from ever being reached.
The heritability for height might now go from
0.8 down to 0.5.
Nature and nurture are now equally responsible
for group differences.
This means, heritability changes.
If we have a well nourished population on
the one side and a malnourished group on the
other, then the impact of nutrition on the
differences in height changes from 20% to
50%.
In other words, nurture matters a lot, until
we reach a point from which it's not as relevant.
So what about intelligence?
The heritability of IQ is around 0.6 for people
in their twenties and then increases as we
age.
The average IQ in our group will be around
100.
But some have an IQ of 110.
Genes are therefore responsible for 60% of
the difference, and random factors and the
environment for about 40%.
In other words, for those with an IQ of 110,
6 of the additional 10 points, can, on average,
be attributed to nature and 4 points to nurture.
Now even if nurture plays a big role, it doesn't
mean that teachers or parents had any impact.
Unlike height, which we know how to increase
through nutrition, when it comes to IQ we
don’t know much about how to improve it.
Random factors seem to play a big role.
How random the environment is, becomes clear
when we look at two kids that are born into
the same family.
Both are raised in the same shared environment,
but firstborns, on average, turn out to be
more intelligent than their younger siblings.
And if one of two siblings was adopted, the
two would have some correlation in IQ during
their upbringing, but as adults they would
be hardly more similar in intelligence than
complete strangers.
Parents, it seems, have a very limited impact
on a child's IQ.
So now what about that crayfish?
In 1995 German scientists made an odd observation.
The little female creature had mutated and
become asexual — able to make clones of
itself.
As each clone shared exactly the same genetic
blueprint, the scientists set up an experiment
for the ultimate test.
Hundreds of these little identical creatures
were placed in the same environment.
Same water, same temperature, same amount
of food.
Even though the scientists tried to control
all these variables, the unthinkable happened.
Some crayfish stayed tiny, others grew big.
Some died, others lived on and on.
And while some became social, others enjoyed
solitude.
Why do you think that happened?
Is that nature, nurture or a complex interplay
of the two with some random variations in
replicated genetic code?
To download this video without background
music, and to learn more about the topic,
visit SproutsSchools.com
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.